[Music]
get ready for Episode three of The
Hobbit trilogy that's the best in the
series because it finally finally means
it's over
kind of like episode 3 The Hobbit the
Battle of the five armies resign
yourself to another Hobbit movie once
again filled with faceless CGI armies
slamming into each other elves define
the basic laws of physics and people
making out-of-place references to Lord
of the Rings
as a young Ranger amongst them is known
in the wild as Strider now Peter Jackson
will finish picking through tokens bones
and put an end to our long expected
journey and will rack our brains to come
up with anything new to say about these
movies hope you remember what happened
in the desolation of Smaug because
you're about to enter a disorienting
dragon Holocaust already in progress
that clearly should have been the end of
the second movie but wasn't once again
Martin Freeman shines in his well acted
charming portrayal of Bilbo Baggins and
once again he's turned into an extra in
his own movie because once again it's
all about the mopey dwarf king who's
grown from a mopey dick brooding over
his lost gold to a mopey dick brooding
over his found gold in a plotting
storyline about dragon-sickness that
finally pays off when he just kind of
decides he's not sick anymore huh
everyone wants a piece of the treasure
within Scrooge McGregor's vault
five pages of a children's book will be
stretched into an hour-long battle
between five to eight different armies
depending on how you count full of lazy
action cliches like easy bloodless
decapitations last-second rescues heroes
talking to each other in the middle of a
raging battle there's too many of these
Augustana I hope you get applied Gandalf
and Bilbo giving play-by-play commentary
and of course the Eagles because you
can't make a middle-earth movie with
that the Biggles showing up the last
second now can you and I hate the
[ __ ] old man you cried the last time
Peter Jackson wrapped up a trilogy with
aragorn's final charge for our time now
cry tears of relief as you say goodbye
to characters you spent eight hours with
and still don't remember their names oh
no not that one finally roll your eyes
at the tacked on epilogue as old Bilbo
writes down his story sixty years later
and we can only imagine how a book that
was actually based on these movies would
be received hmm I wonder what that would
have looked like what did you think
well it's good but it was kind of long
almost like you were trying to stretch
it out unnecessarily hmm you really
could have cut some of that stuff out oh
well it's an epic quest I'm not really
sure why we needed to know what Gandalf
was up to or what that else lady was
there for or what Legolas his purpose
was
I wish universe building for a book
called hobbits tail you kind of
disappeared halfway through lots of
dwarf I like I can't be everywhere at
once
also what exactly were the five armies
it's kind of unclear
yeah that's sidekick from the master of
Laketown wolf talked about a character
that goes nowhere well since you have so
many bright ideas why don't you try it
and sorry it was just so serious his
might have worked better as a children's
book story
kill no dragons dwarfee downer ian
mckellen stunt of all
Christopher Lee stunt double old Lando
bloom Khaleesi
tremors l ron hubbard the girl from the
ring but they a goes to Laketown
see you wait wait is that that Bryan
Cranston and the New Zealand Department
of Tourism The Hobbit the glowing of the
five pages
you know what the sad thing is this is
probably the best scene in the movie be
sure to subscribe for more honest
trailers thanks to our friends at how it
should have in it for the awesome
animation click the box below to check
out the premiere of their take on The
Hobbit the Battle of the five armies and
tell him screen junkie sent you I'm
givin it all she's got captain mega
maids gone from suck to blow potatoes
our BAE I will eat you I'm the bacon in
the fridge booty booty booty booty
rockin everywhere dumb dumb give me the
gum gum